now with the midterms only 42 days away
well Biden's border failures are in full
Focus as now Democrats are more
desperate than ever to distract from
Biden's failures and of course desperate
to demonize Republicans at all costs get
this a new poll finding a majority of
the American people are now supporting
sending illegal immigrants to
democratic-run cities as border
communities in Texas and Arizona
continue to suffer under what is now an
undeniable catastrophe caused by Joe
Biden Arizona Senator Mark Kelly he is a
rubber stamp for the entire Biden agenda
he voted for every single major piece of
legislation backed by Biden he has
refused to hold the administration
accountable for any of their open border
failures and of course he is now in
election year conversion mode trying to
pretend that he's some sort of moderate
like Kristen simina a cinema who cares
about Safety and Security that is a
complete lie here to explain anymore
Republican Arizona Senate candidate and
Arizona Blake Masters all right your
race is crucial uh let's go to the issue
of the border and start there because
Mark Kelly has again and again had an
opportunity to help secure the border
and he's failed to do so why
he just has no independence of mind Sean
he promised arizonans that he would be
independent he swore he would be a
moderate a lot of people believed that
well for the last two years Mark Kelly
has been voting in lockstep for Joe
Biden's agenda and apparently he's just
fine with this wide open Southern border
because he hasn't done a single thing to
stop it you know we've had more than
five million illegal aliens come into
this country welcomed by Joe Biden and
Mark Kelly they're resettling these
people in working class towns and cities
in Arizona and working-class towns and
cities throughout the country I have no
idea why because it's hurting people
it's hurting families it's making our
streets less safe the fentanyl that's
coming in is killing children here in
Arizona but apparently Mark Kelly likes
it this way he's not doing a darn thing
to stop unforgivable I got his record he
voted against the bill that would have
funded greater greater opioid detection
capability voted against title 42 three
times he voted against hiring a eighteen
thousand border patrol agents but
supports the eighty seven thousand IRS
agents to be hired you've got top law
enforcement officials saying that he's
been completely absent absent on public
safety and border security guys like
Brandon Judd and the Arizona Police
Association but somehow it seems It's a
you're tightening in the polls but it
seems like so far he's gotten a pass has
anybody in the media in Arizona been
challenging him on these issues
we've got a pretty left-wing media in
Arizona and so it's really just me we're
getting the message out it's my
Grassroots Army Sean I can't tell you
how pissed off and activated are
Republicans in Arizona are The
Independents in Arizona everybody says
Arizona is a purple State no it's not
this is a red State the independence by
two to one in Arizona they know that Joe
Biden's failed and as they learn about
Mark Kelly's record they're going to
want to make a change here in November
all right Blake Masters very important
pickup if the Republicans can get that
seat thanks for being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else